incroyable voilà le rêve c'était
vraiment mon rêve depuis vraiment
c'était comme tu l'imaginais c'était
encore mieux après de le vivre c'est
indescriptible c'est une aventure
incroyable besoin de te préparer
physiquement tu t'écoutes sportives donc
forcément j'ai eu besoin de me préparer
physiquement tout simplement car je
m'étais baissé avant l'aventure donc
j'étais en pleine rééducation
du plateau tibial en match de tennis
quand tu veux tennis c'est combien j'ai
été deux six à 17h
de 6 à 10 non c'est moins 30
de 6 une femme de 6 me bat pas alors
tu as déjà fait le pari j'ai joué contre
ta copine lag et que Benoît Paire il a
perdu 400 balles elle était 3 6 elle a
pris un donc je t'explique arrêté ouais
mais non mais c'est pareil 3 6 2 6 c'est
1 et 1 contre moi tout de suite c'est un
et un c'est tous les jours et j'ai pas
touché j'ai pas touché une raquette
depuis 4 ans donc je te le dis euh je
sais pas vous êtes presque combien non
mais je perds ça 15
ans garçon honnêtement je mets un billet
tout de suite tu penses que tu me bats
je pense honnêtement
[Applaudissements]
ça mérite quand même un petit match
non mais non mais je me laisse moi tu me
laisses pas moi je me remets
à ta copine elle a été elle a été 5 6
elle a été moins forte 5 6 elle a pris
donc c'est bon
on joue quand tu veux il lâcher là il
est pas venu pour ça
c'est vrai tellement fiable
je te jure qu'on va le faire les filles
parce que je vais je vais je vais les
c'est quoi le pari le pari très simple
franchement je mange je mange un rat
voilà en plus
tu étais de 6 maintenant je crois que je
suis 15 enfin je redescends tous les ans
merci en tout cas c'est quelque chose à
pas que tu parles un peu tennis
dis-moi
tu as malheureusement été éliminé dans
l'épisode d'hier soir tu l'avais même
pas vu venir en plus tu as pas vu venir
le truc ouais vraiment alors arrêt petit
résumé de l'histoire pour mieux
comprendre regardez
alors qu'elle était à deux doigts de se
faire dégager la semaine dernière Tania
se sente en confiance après son
changement d'équipe ça j'ai l'impression
que c'est peut-être un peu moins sur la
sellette comme avant tu vois j'ai
beaucoup plus de chance de poursuivre
mon aventure ici que dans l'équipe des
jaunes honnêtement je suis trop contente
elle est tellement en confiance qu'elle
en a plus rien à faire de son ancienne
équipe elle tout ce qu'elle veut c'est
resté avec Rudy
et pas en ex jaune donc bon après c'est
drôle comment les choses s'inversent et
que pendant Koh-Lanta tout peut changer
quoi mais oui tu es plus sur la
signature tu que ton meilleur ami Rudy
le chef des rouges il sait très bien ce
qu'il fait lui je pense que le petit
groupe qui prêt de jamais se faire
défaut c'est Esteban Anne-Sophie Tania
et moi moi je te demande de me faire
confiance c'est super dur ce que je te
donne relax Tania
Tania Tania les aventuriers d'attribu
rouge ont décidé de vous éliminer et
leur sentence est tirer vos quatre
Tania a donc est-ce que tu as compris
cette illumination ou bien pour toi
c'était pas mérité
donc oui je comprends l'élimination on a
joué ils ont été meilleurs que moi mais
c'est vrai que je l'ai pas du tout vu
venir j'étais dans des types avec des
regrets ou pas non pas de regrets que ce
soit dans la vie ou dans Koh-Lanta tout
arrive pour une raison donc pas de
regret pour toi c'est qui qui va être le
grand gagnant de cette saison
je sais pas vraiment je ne sais pas
j'aimerais bien que ce soit un de mes
alliés
ça va chéri
merci
Daniel c'est par la ma chérie t'inquiète
pas et puis
par contre par contre attention
oh c'est mon calme là toi et juste écrit
ton testament
il y a eu des rumeurs de d'un
rapprochement dans ce colenta on a
beaucoup parlé de toi aussi et où les
mecs avec Benji Benjamin
et Benjamin on va revoir l'image vous
avez dormi collé-serré
ôter quelqu'un danser si tu es prêt
partant pour nous décaler c'est vrai que
vous avez dormi collé-serré et moi moi
pour moi pour moi
je dormirai pas polycérine avec
quelqu'un s'il y a pas de bail comme ça
et tu verras l'expérience que ça alors
on va revoir et tu vas nous dire moi je
te donne voilà moi je l'aurais pas moi
regarde
c'est ça aussi la survie
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc voilà
Erwin qui me dit de 6 filles tu gagnes
mon Cyril ça joue 15 de Home voilà merci
voilà merci merci
très bien et elle a pas envie d'aller
sur ce terrain
Tania juste est-ce que la grande
question tout le monde se pose à 20h20
en direct sur C8 est-ce que tu la
galoche
du tout non mais il faut savoir sur
Koh-Lanta c'est impossible de ganache
ah c'est vraiment je vous jure que c'est
la survie avant tout qu'on l'a voilà on
dans mes collés
serrésil
là il y a quand même un chevauchement
moi oui vous avez aussi l'image on est
tous ensemble witch on est cinq
personnes donc on était tous collés
et j'adore Benjamin je pense qu'il lui
voulait te pécho c'est pas possible
mais il voulait pas me me pécho
normalement
parce que là vous avez dormi comme ça
toute nue parce que là tu as quand même
le genou
c'est facile de mettre les deux
célibataires on a on a pas de toujours
célibataire ou pas oui on a pas de quoi
j'ai gardé contact avec lui c'est
vraiment un très bon ami à moi
qui n'arrêter de l'emberti donc là il y
a même pas et toi tu es même pas c'était
même pas traversé l'esprit de de
premier soir si vous avez les images on
était tous ensemble c'est pas pareil
vous imaginez bien que chez les jaunes
parce que moi personne toute la journée
j'allais pas coller en Quentin Frédéric
ou en Nicolas avec qui je ne parlais pas
du tout dans la journée
non mais j'ai analysé les images avec
les équipes c'est comme c'est une
position de couple ça vous êtes même pas
un peu pécho dans la matière non
vraiment pas dans la bonne humeur
j'aimerais on n'a jamais vu ça dans
Koh-Lanta des images comme ça ah bah
c'est tout tous les ans il y a des
personnes qui
tout le monde s'est dit vous êtes tous
les deux célibataires ça dort comme ça
il y a que nous avons été montré on va
pas casser une famille ou peu importe
enfin
pour toi pour toi Dylan est-ce que ça
s'est pécho bon bah non bah pour moi
c'est juste qu'ils avaient froid il y a
pas de couverture bah normal c'est la
survie quoi
[Applaudissements]
vous puez de la gueule
on s'habitue à tout d'accord même la
puanteur on l'a ressent même plus
quotidien
t'as pas eu de crush là-bas on pense
vraiment pas à ça c'était pas mon but
j'aurais fait une autre émission
tu étais pas du tout là-dedans quoi pas
du tout hier on a eu Elodie qui a vécu
une drôle de semaine après n'avoir
participé à aucune épreuve depuis le
début c'était son grand moment hier soir
et tous ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
regardez
vous vous souvenez tous d'Élodie notre
candidat préféré c'est le cas confondu
Koh-Lanta is the Voice
[Musique]
celle qui est aussi le chat noir de
l'émission celle qui n'a fait aucune
épreuve à cause des boules noires
ouvrez
Elodie troisième Boule Noire
savent pas du tout ce que je vaux bon
bah ça tombe bien là enfin pu participer
à une épreuve cette semaine allez
montre-nous ce que tu veux Élodie allez
non non non
c'est terminé le dit au revoir Élodie au
revoir merci Salut Élodie salut
[Rires]
également celui qui critique tout en
permanence qui était aussi de retour
cette semaine et du coup avec la refonte
des équipes il a dû s'intégrer de
nouveau dans une tribu sauf que vu qu'il
a le caractère de Gilles Verdez a été
compliqué regardez
de tomber dans cette équipe Martin
râleur a changé d'équipe et qui dit
nouvelle équipe dit nouveaux amis mais
pour ça elle va peut-être falloir
arrêter de tout critiquer tout le temps
non non c'est parce qu'on est en train
d'étouffer mais je ne sais rien
tu penses Martin je pense qu'il est ou
du bon côté il va manger tais-toi voilà
profite de ton après-midi fais-toi tout
petit ça va c'est juste une petite
embrouille sur le feu elle va pas lui en
tenir rigueur je suis sûr que c'est
passé déjà
et les gars apprenez une marmite et les
gars hey les gars
marquerez les gars et les gars prenez
une marmite et les gars il dit ça tout
le temps vraiment non les gars
ça va prendre oh les gars ça fait
tellement de bien non mais tais-toi en
fait tais-toi bon ça se passait bien tes
tours
voilà ça vient d'arriver je viens de
comprendre
pour toi pendant cette saison tu as eu
des lettres des gens des internautes oui
j'en ai eu quelques enfin quelques-unes
ça me fait plaisir tu as pas eu de
rencontre derrière
je vais faire du shopping ou alors on me
reconnaît maintenant mais bon grâce à
Koh-Lanta quoi ah non mais j'ai pas fait
Koh-Lanta pour trouver l'amour hein
non pas du tout non pas comme ça elle
est dans le tennis tennis tennis de tes
conneries là Dylan ça va toi ouais ça va
tranquille
non parce que c'est la beauté intérieure
qui compte
non mais parce que parce que oui mais
oui mais je sais pas mais même les
pagresser les qualités c'est les
qualités des personnes qui comptent on
peut pas juger je pense que même à
l'intérieur est très sympathique et vu
que c'est une sportive c'est une
sportive je la sens très saine j'aime
beaucoup
Monsieur c'est pas parce qu'elle est
belle que dans calme-toi
on sent aussi qu'après 31 31 saisons de
Koh-Lanta les gars galèrent de plus en
plus pour trouver des idées d'épreuves
par exemple celle d'hier soir je suis
toujours en train d'essayer de
comprendre les règles c'est encore plus
dur qu'une question de 100% logique sur
France 2 regarder
3 paires de pierres la première paire
est à 15 mètres la deuxième à 20 mètres
la troisième paire à 25 mètres à une
profondeur de 3 mètres 10 et ce qui est
important de savoir il y a une corde
qui rend deux pierres dans une même
paire solidaire c'est un relais et vous
allez devoir mettre en place un ordre de
passage qui sera immuable
alors
on vous a fait un petit résumé d'hier et
on a une candidate qui voilà qui peut
dire des gros mots Denis Brognard un peu
trop philosophe une erreur folle de la
petite erreur de la production ce qui
s'est passé dans Koh-Lanta hier soir
regardez
en bref dans Koh-Lanta on a croisé une
candidate bien trop vulgaire quand elle
gagne au jeu c'est bon pour être Sophie
et on a aussi entendu Denis Brogniart
sortir des expressions mais à pas piquer
des hannetons
futé Tania avance prudemment et ménage
la chèvre et le chou les jaunes sont
loin d'imaginer de telles
embrouillamines et cette semaine il y
avait Benjamin le pauvre Benjamin qui a
du sortir de l'émission sur blessure le
sudiste Benjamin ne se sent pas bien je
vais vous prendre avec moi l'infirmerie
pour surveiller votre douleur pour être
sûr qu'il y ait pas d'infection aussi
qui se rajoute à votre titre espérons
que Benjamin se remette vite Benjamin
va-t-il se remettre vite mais sera-t-il
là la semaine prochaine je ne sais pas
c'est un énorme suspense ah on me dit
que TF1 vient de spoiler à cause du
teaser de la semaine prochaine
sur TF1
bon ben on se revoit la sculpture
alors Tania tu le referais
actuellement je ne sais pas c'est pas un
oui c'est pas un an mais c'est pas un
moment je suis en train de revivre mon
aventure avec les images donc j'ai pas
forcément l'envie et le besoin dire tu
regardes toutes les semaines ou pas bah
bien sûr
en famille je suis obligé de le faire en
famille par contre c'est très important
pour moi mais voilà toujours des amis à
la maison après c'est un peu compliqué
aussi parce que tout le monde parle en
même temps et nous on a envie de
regarder mais bon
replay le week-end avec des amis on
parle en même temps
entre vous là vous avez pardonné à tout
le monde parce que Esteban quand même
vous a trahi Rudy vous a mal protégé
aujourd'hui vous leur en voulez encore
quand vous avez revu hier par exemple
alors faut pas oublier que enfin
Koh-Lanta c'est un jeu et je suis pas du
tout en cuir je vais essayer de faire la
part des choses entre la vie réelle et
le jeu donc bien évidemment j'ai
pardonné à tout le monde c'est enfin
honnêtement c'est un jeu individuel donc
le but c'est que Esteban même s'il a
voté contre moi il aille le plus long
possible c'est pas
une personnalité oui mais après je
trouve aussi que Koh-Lanta ça représente
un peu aussi la vie
il m'a dit c'est ça
non plus des nouvelles connaissances
équipe de muratoglou et il me dit
vraiment il me dit chérie Cyril je
t'aime bien c'est mon entraîneur c'était
mon horaire il m'a dit de six femmes
excuse-moi de te dire ça c'est une
boucherie mais pas
après vous jouez mieux que de 6 femmes
il faut tenter
pas tu vas être grotesque non pas du
tout
il y a autant de chance que je ferme
j'étais pas concerné alors si je perds
si je perds contre Tania je t'explique
je déglingue
je déglingrais mon voilà
Tania merci en tout cas un amour voilà
et merci d'avoir été là merci
[Applaudissements]